we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p today's
voicemail caller is making a very very
serious accusation against me take a
listen to this hey David I can't help
but feel a little bummed out about the
whole interest on voting process I mean
I think option two is the best and I
really like the song so I went back to
the video to listen to it again today
and I realized that you had edited the
YouTube video to like make the quality
lower on the song and I don't know if
that's like really unfair yeah obviously
and you know it's just a psychological
fact that people usually only remember
the first and last items in the list
then you clearly like put number two
second to make people not remember it I
don't know why you had to spice against
it all like my friend said that they
preferred number two as well listen we
it would not even occur to me to but by
the way I don't do the editing to say to
Pat listen go back in and reduce
something to make this particular song
sound bad because I don't want people to
like that song that we don't have the
time to do this it would never occur to
me to do something like that we did
nothing of the sort just not a lot of
people like number two and your thought
that most people like the first or last
thing that they hear that's not true we
had six songs and most the the plurality
liked song number four which is right in
the middle so you're wrong on the facts
you're wrong about the assessment and I
take personal offense to the allegation
that we would do anything like that
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about the five
industries being hardest hit by Trump's
China tariffs at least a couple of them
might surprise you we will also talk
about a reusable bag that a study found
makes people think users of this bag are
gay which makes no sense but we will
talk about the study and I will also
tell you about I've alluded to the
before I'm going to talk about the
problems with MRIs for low back pain and
the sort of garden path into the medical
world that it will often open at very
limited but to very bit of to very
limited benefit better said to the
patients and I've talked about this a
little bit before but now we actually
have some significant data about it so
that's all on the bonus show there's two
ways to get the bonus show become a
member at join pakman.com if you like
the regular show you will like the bonus
show so sign up if you don't want to
become a member and why you wouldn't is
beyond me but imagine for a second
someone didn't want to be a member
become a patron for at least five bucks
a month and you'll get access to that
same bonus show at patreon.com slash
david pakman show it's great to be back
from the holiday weekend a very packed
week with some very special guests I
will have to announce a little bit later
on this week